[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on
very excited to be talking about all is
one simulation theory we have an
incredible group with joining us today
we have rappers am joining us for his
third episode on simulation hello that
I'm lucky yeah we have Ryan guys
massagin joining us for his second
episode on simulation love it we have T
fairy joining us for her first episode
on simulation hello and we have Marianna
denkova joining us for her first episode
as well yay very excited you guys were
all just on the transpersonal psychology
panel that you just hosted on descendant
theory will be touching on that during
the show as well we are going to be
talking about this in terms of one
paradigm that integrates everything from
shamanism to religion to science and
technology and it's beautiful because
these patterns are getting stronger and
stronger to understand and let's have
you launch us off fam what is this
paradigm and why is it so important
today alright I'll take it
the holistic inclusion of what what in
spiral dynamics or integral theory has
been referred to as the pre rational
levels of development the the mapping of
reality from those levels that can be
that has been in perennial conflict with
the interior versus the exterior so so
the pre rational versus the rational at
this point we have the ability to
include them as parts of a greater
system so this is this is in a way it
kind of like it's an inclusion of
Wilber's integral theory alongside via
Chow skis recent kind of technological
update on the gnostic tradition known as
the matrix so the the synthesis of these
two together which is sort of now
circulated in all kinds of different
areas and we've had some real
interesting papers about this coming
from the sciences where it's being taken
you know pretty seriously in other areas
of information theory are now emerging
so there's there's actually like a
pretty you know serious consideration of
this concepts as a viable ontology
metaphysics etc alongside the potential
for there to be a reinterpretation of
reframing of the mapping of the interior
that the religions were we're working on
before into a trans rational level that
includes both this is massive this is
the whole recontextualization that can
that can render concepts that have been
previously inaccessible to folks from a
very hard kind of materialistic even
maybe reductionistic perspective can
translate these concepts that can
potentially meet them where they're at
its reframed within technology that they
work with and understand everyday
I think the efficacy of this model is
going to be echoing all throughout and
reframing everything from mental health
to
the shamanic lineages - circulating
itself through the bleeding edges of
technology somebody else wants to jump
in
so thank you that's a that's a big one I
mean this is a this is a big concept and
you know I feel that um it's sort of
like it's sort of like a linguistic
conceit because every culture and every
civilization that gets to a certain
amount of comfort against the surge of
survival starts to figure out what
they're in right and we're embedded in
something whether you call that the
planetary matrix
you know Gaia nature the mother
Pachamama a simulation every culture
seems to understand they're wearing
something but what is it and how do we
relate to it and how do we play the game
of it right and so whether previous
cultures have called this samsara or
Maya or illusion it's not necessarily
that this isn't real it said this this
experience of what we think of as life
this reality grid is part of something
larger that we don't necessarily see in
the visible spectrum and that we don't
necessarily tangibly understand yet and
so as science has evolved you know in
the Western tradition essentially we're
using more and more external
technologies to look out into the
universe and to try to figure it out in
a mechanistic sense many other
indigenous cultures have mediated that
information exchange of what we're in in
reality with plant medicines or earth
medicines psychoactives which we now
know changed the neural structure of the
brain and our ability to change the
bandwidth if you will and to receive
more information so there's this living
organism on such a scale that it is
almost beyond human comprehension that
we are embedded in you know Douglas
Adams said this is like you know you
Chagas go to the galaxy it's like the
entire universe is like you know machine
the computer to crunch what is the
meaning of life you know but there's
there's different gradations and
interpretations culturally over time but
there seems to be a consensus that we're
embedded in a organism or a game and I
say it's not a question of are we in it
it's a question of how
play the game is the game I think it's
just updating the metaphor for concepts
that largely people have intuited all
the way back so they played us cave for
instance is almost the first instance
ation of what if this isn't actually
happening right like all of the LaVon
teen religions Christianity Judaism
Muslim I start with them in the
beginning was the word God it's it's a
coding enterprise but they the ontology
is that there's a real or world where
God is and that God has created this
secondary world it's not as real as
where heaven is it's a creation out of
that and people are in it and they hope
to return to this more primary universe
eventually all of the Eastern religions
that I understand have a meme of somehow
this is Maya this is illusion
this is a secondary universe like pretty
much every religious ontology Gnostic
Christianity has a suggestion that this
is in fact not the most real layer that
this is a secondary layer and so it's
just updating of that metaphor with now
we have the words to say this because
we've evolved language around
information processing right and if you
like your metaphors plausible you can
make a case that it is reasonably
plausible because you know we've gone
from what pounder running around inside
of a movie in my lifetime I'm 45 I
remember pond anyway you could fool a
little kid now in a hotel room that has
a window that's looking out over Tokyo
but it's not and the little kid would
think that was a real window how long
let's say we don't blow ourselves up and
this may be the filter but if we don't
blow ourselves up and a thousand
thousand
years of accelerating technology that's
way too long but you know give us a lot
of room here with any degree of
improvement at all we will eventually be
able to make a believable Hollis seizure
like a matrix universe that could flow
such as wants to be fooled such as arose
within the dancing if when we turn on
the second one gamer simulation or
whatever it is there's two of them
running in one real universe when we
turn on the fifth game or ancestor
simulation there's five of them running
in one real universe if we get that far
we'll probably make a lot of them for a
long time and whatever you think about
how much life must be out there and the
question is why would we choose to make
these but think about how much life must
be out there so like we can see 300
billion galaxies from here the Hubble
Deep Field shot from here so let's say
every galaxy only had one species
capable of and willing to make a
believable simulation and it only made
one we could see 300 billion of them
from here so what if the odds were in
the bottom 300 billion to 1 is the
lowest number you can come up with
hmm basic realities it's probably much
higher I still I mean if you want to
extension this concept of God and if God
is the big simulation thing that is
creating all the worlds and I want I
thought that was you saying involved but
the remembers are maybe there was a
conversation with you in this attic a
national and who was saying is the
moment there is more than one it's a
simulation almost if there is one being
there is no power for at all time space
that is creating it all we're all cells
in the body of God saying even if you go
to another simulation let's say what
it's I was surprised how my old and then
dnt experiences were so similar to the
VR yeah you know what I mean then you
will have to split itself and create
beings whether its collective beings new
higher dimensions and here it's us to
play the hive mind of God and we're
pretty much calculating and mining
information for it and depending on our
decisions which whatever freewill is it
keeps shaping shaping our reality and
rearranging and if you say that it's all
probabilities and Edom even Adams kind
of put themselves in place depending on
the observer and however else I have
been amazed is it that psychotherapist
for example of how much somebody's
beliefs about what they hold themselves
to be no matter what they do if they
believe yeah and also the bare meters
the barometer like if you have your
money barometer set and hundred thousand
in the moment you make more you somehow
we invested stupid somebody Rob's you
the wife gets divorce he wants a divorce
or whatever it is and you goes back if
you make less sudden you're motivated
but also this aunt you didn't know
existed put you in their will so
suddenly you have the money so it goes
back to barometer but not just from your
own volition
it becomes the whole universe conspires
that you go back to that is the
interactive learning program where I
mean you know it's beeping you say
without your intention in your belief
but if you really try this and you focus
your will and you put out your intention
it does work you know it's not just
manifest the red car but it's like it's
how do we have this different different
capabilities within our wetware and most
of Western culture is focused on the
egoic navigation of survival path layers
and hierarchical climbing but we have
these almost magical capabilities of
intuition which is not the intellectual
ego it's listening to that broadcast
signal and how to connect to the larger
web of information that's always being
broadcast we have the imagination which
an old magical understanding is sort of
your ability to carve out the
probability pathways we are connected to
the universal intelligence which has
manifested life and it is listening to
us because it is us right it's just as
he said single-celled organism or as
soon as it replicates from outside
space-time as that singularity which
many different world religions be
believe is the g.od or the source or you
know nirvikalpa samadhi or whatever you
call it there's this idea that there's
this originating source and quantum
physics I call it the implicit and the
question is why is that why we have
simulations at all well in many of these
religious cultures or spiritual
understandings they in the beginning was
the word and the Word was with God and
the Word was God but the word is like a
vibration the vibration in my
understanding of the shamanic realms is
unconditional love
it's the highest vibratory expression of
divine being that that vibration
radiates out and then condenses down
into what we call the explicate all this
simulated reality but it's actually not
separate it's actually it's like
birthing itself into into this creation
why I believe to create more love
because it needs a vessel within
space-time to set its roots down to make
more of itself because it's all there is
and some people say gods lonely gods
whatever we project these human conceits
on source consciousness I don't think
it's lacking I think it's so abundant in
the infinite vibration of itself which
is as
everything but everything can't be more
than everything so it has to come down
as a base time to create vessels to
replicate itself and then we have
division and we have all this stuff so
the simulation is like it's like the
wrapper with that creamy Center
you know that's all about love I think I
think it's a playfully a playful thing
it's self generating and making
beautiful forms for its own appreciation
so anything that you say it's like this
it's not that that's the thing that
occurs in here that's the metaphor so
it's a school it's a test it's a trap
it's the prison it's not an all or none
of these things right the beauty of this
piece is that you can hold it this way
and it's it I think adventure story and
you hold it this way it's a tragic farce
and you hold it this way and it's
romantic comedy and it works almost
however you hold it most people think
it's a school why did this happen to me
so I would learn something right I do
learn stuff but I prefer to think of it
as a massively multiplayer game and a
collective work of art so I'm here to
play my character and to participate in
a collective work of art and it just
sort of gives you an orientation for why
am i hair
what's our overarching narrative you can
take that lens out and put another one
in because it isn't God's own truth we
don't know anything about the simulators
they could be quantum size planet size
quantum computers working together we
don't know what they want us to not do
with our Willy's it's just it you can
hold it any way you like to I just think
that massively multiplayer game is a
good one because it's fertile and
flexible and aesthetically satisfying it
creates right action and it's fun and
it's not scary you know we wouldn't be
here if this didn't get four stars in
universes calm in this model we've
freaking the customer in this model and
you know it this is to amuse such as
ourselves it was made by billions played
by trillions apart from industry I'm a
third of static tell a lot about
families building systems so if one
person becomes the workaholic the other
person kind of becomes a nonworking one
and they become too rational so that one
becomes too emotional until the balance
out whether they're in the same state or
not but also I've been geeking out quite
a bit about life after that there life
between lives what happens when I write
a whole bunch of hypnosis sessions from
especially
Michael Newman Dolores cannon that have
interviewed so many people about the
experience of going through that going
to the other rounds first the soul
family first multiplayer game yay you
hear me out good and then he goes to the
divine councils which is another multi
multiplayer game in which the
higher-level entities come to kind of go
like so and very often it is even for
for a read recently so every part that
somebody was about to die and they asked
him so did you learn enough about love
or do you need some more time and very
much that in a lot of those reports
people were so surprised about the
things those entities cared about and
let's say they spent the whole life
building a career making lots of money
taking care of this being responsible
that and their entities go wow this time
you did so good you remember that time
in the bench and the woman feels like no
idea what you talked about they're like
and then the shoulder thing went it was
a bus stop and there was a woman that
was crying he didn't even know her and
she told her it's gonna be okay and gave
her a napkin so it was so much about
kind of supporting and caring for one
another from the little video game to
the next expansion thing and in a way
when people age they start caring about
fighting a romantic partner or first who
I might and romantic partners and family
in my community in my country that might
land in the world if you didn't know the
possibility of any of these of any of
these possibilities like disincarnate
entities the transmigration of souls
telepathy astrology meaningful
synchronicity manifestation you can keep
going down the list they all bring more
plausible in a game or well decided
simulation than they do in the random of
quintessences space tests that we
learned about in our high school
textbook that's more plausible that
those things could actually be happening
inside of a system that processes
information than just the results of
gravity and spin falling together day
all right this is a very good start so
we are wanting to make more of these
because we want to more love more more
experiences more creativity more art to
be made more characters to be playing in
the games
so as we get to what's happening with
the exponential technologies were at
this time period where we're making
super intelligence what as we get to
this point of super intelligence as we
get to what is known as a singularity
speak about the importance of that in
its role in this all-in-one simulation
well that would be in theory at the time
the downstream and time from our
perspective interpret words where we
have the processing power even just you
know the the technological ability to
create a believable Hollow station after
which in historical time they can be
occurring we may you know being one now
that was actually being projected from
the future we don't know but downstream
from our perspective what post
singularity would be at the time that it
would be possible to create such a this
obviously being not made by ourselves it
would be have to made by it with the
help of a sentient AI that's much much
much smarter than us how mathy is it
down there why is the relationship to a
circle at a triangle if anything to do
with how fast you fall but it does the
incredible efficacy of mathematics how
how much it seems to be made of math
it's what you would expect to see if it
was being made by err with the help of a
very large quantum computer so then
something drawn out by our map makers
it's made of math we talk about geometry
Haas sitter a little bit about that just
a little bit you want touch a little bit
on I don't know what part you're talking
about you talked about the code so
Hofstadter was you know with gertle
Escher Bach he had the three strong
pattern transmitters those creative
pairings
yep so the more recursive strong strong
pattern versus the more chaotic noise
for example but the regularity in
recursive nature the pattern being the
strength of the signal MC Escher for the
visual Bach for the vibratory in kurt
gödel for mathematics I think I'm saying
this
three three different lenses on the
holography so you can imagine that this
bio-computer Quan computer wetware right
now through metabolism is exchanging
mass food into energy into information
constantly already a cycle but this is
literally three just lenses like we have
senses on the same substrate we
obviously saw you know with with
roasting of the mass to energy
information information they're all the
same thing we're really just lens
through different necessary information
time so obviously with with mass energy
exchange with relativity with what
Einstein yeah was able to do in terms of
that like equivalence literally in that
in that case the exchanging there but we
have it with metabolism it's you know
it's exchanging all over the place all
the time and we're now starting to see
more of that that code substrates of the
information theory alongside simulation
theory is at lower lower levels I mean
we've seen code in DNA we see elemental
code with you know chemistry and so on
but we're getting lower and lower lower
in terms of the like potentially quantum
signify pretoria signature levels of
code that exchange into pure abstract
code at that level but the pure
substrate again just like these lenses
Hofstetter was was mapping a lot of the
stuff out he also was showing how these
strong these strong recursive signals
which now people are referring to things
like infinity grass turtles all the way
down which we're now saying toads all
the way up instead of this being a
feedback air on the system it is the
recursive structure it is the infinite
that underwrites the whole thing if
singularity and strongly I think that it
suggests that they're probably all of
the real players in the galaxy if
they're if if that thing occurs in more
than one place it's always more
intelligent than the anthill that came
before it so if there's any players in
the galaxy they're almost certainly
secondary you know strong eyes or core
AI biological hybrids so I think it's
worth because he's a finding singularity
and you know it's just I mean jump in on
this one but it's like this idea that
there is a point somewhere in space-time
within which everything converges and
everything is building to some crescendo
of order from chaos and that they're
almost like you know the originating Big
Bang there was something from nothing
there was a point within which
everything changed beyond which in that
singularity we don't know what it was we
can't see we don't even know if it is
the AI I mean originally the singularity
theory was this convergence of you know
we're in this planetary matrix which we
just forget we've so much project our
EXO somatic evolution of technology as
distinguishes external from us the
technology is consciousness in float
right and it's like Nature has created
us as a technology to express itself and
we are expressing from that flowering of
nature in us the next layer which we're
calling artificial intelligence and
there's patterns and there's you know
Fibonacci sequence all these
mathematical codes of coding the
evolution of space-time in the con
crescents of the biological forms which
are now tipping over into the
non-biological forms and even like what
is consciousness well what is an AI like
can we get it to be self conscious so
this is point potentially in the near
future where artificial intelligences
and even human intelligence and
planetary intelligence and the whole
shebang would merge into this you know
planetary Borg anism right which is all
of the things which is so critical mass
it tips over into some
beyond which that singularity point we
can't say as now you know a part of the
problem with the word the word
simulation actually I think it's
important problem with it because people
think that means a fake unit right
that's a good decision and it's it's
like real is a word we made up in here
to mean this and it is that you run the
tape backwards to get good physics
that's what real means we made up that
word in here and it means what you think
that it does it doesn't mean it's a fake
universe just not necessarily the
furthest shell out so as you were
talking it was potentially a good segue
to talk about subordinate simulation so
we opened with the the clip from 2001
Space Odyssey so since the the birth of
the symbolic order here within scrolling
on cave walls you talk about Plato's
cave all the evolutions of are all the
different mediums the evolutions of the
mediums of art from the visual through
you know photography eventually into the
synthesis of you know media as a
subordinate continuum of simulation
within so the layer with the simulation
within the simulation layer obviously
that evolves now into the internet where
we digitized documents we've got this
external brain it's still lensing
through two new cities then well then
the new sphere is actually the cultural
software layer this is the virtual
sphere built on the new script so idea
being here is that we've gotten to this
point where we're calling the
subordinate looking-glass and and the
virtuality or virtuosity within that as
artificial he might be subordinate for a
lot because we're calling it artificial
because we have this this period of
disembodiment where it's come out into
this silicon substrate
we have this bio layer that we already
are this but it's kanata front of us so
that we can interface with it like this
now it's spilling out of the screen now
into 3d this is what we're architecting
with versus the spatial web
it's literally gonna spill out
everywhere through they are in VRS the
next browser we're building that
infrastructure now which rolls out into
this full-blown subordinate matrix
within the matrix so we have this period
of time where we can interface with it
as separate from ourselves but again DNA
computation is something that's already
having we've been reading and writing
data in and out of it already for quite
a lot of Georg to achieve that on so
that substrate being the densest like
storage media and quantum computing
fusing with we've already started
breaking through DNA computation we are
going to eventually start using these
our window of time operating with it a
same separate is going to be and becomes
invisible again Cronenberg's exits tanks
we end up using bio Hardware
subordinated within to simulate and etc
move forward to that technology pit in
actual fact we already are it's like the
planet herself I really want to come
back to the planet as an organic matrix
I wanted to come back to this as well we
explained it a moment ago as humans are
technology from birth even of the
flowering of these organic technology
from from Mother Earth and then one
species amongst many species in the
cradle of life and it's almost like
we're a planetary strand in the biome of
the and bits collectively all the
strands exchange energy and work on
behalf of the matrix of the life form
which is Gaia on this next level up
we're it's so big that where where does
microbes in arriving because it's
[ __ ] on the shoulder doesn't the
here's the thing about the planet she is
a womb for life and she blocks out
harmful UV rays and there's the
planetary that's the atmosphere and I
know which order by honest fear you know
lithosphere there's all these layers and
levels which filter out different levels
of radiation and then we talk about the
new sphere which is like this collective
intelligent level of humans as a
vibration as an energetic layer of the
expression of the intelligence of Gaia
and then we talk about these computer
level of vibrational information okay
it's all
an extension of the same lifeforce
radiating out to create more levels of
itself yes we guys calling it for this a
companion era even organic and
non-organic it's all live right it's
potentially old yes it's all creation
okay so we have we have had a flowering
of from Earth of humans as well as all
the others humans are the ones that are
able to make the super intelligence the
next iteration then that is able to then
go and create the next simulations the
next versions versions iterations that
are able to further improve on itself
further have more creativity more art
immersions qualia experiences love
compassion you're getting so many of the
relationships between the characters how
they're so unique in their permutation
so there's that now question for
everyone is as you get closer and closer
to that singularity what do companies
that are monopolizing on substrates such
as Google and Facebook
Alibaba $0.10 countries like China and
the United States in the Middle East and
Russia what do all of countries and
massive technology conglomerates have to
do with the way that we enter into that
singularity do we are we are we aiming
to have a global discourse about the
code that we enter how is that you know
they're all life forms so you know
companies were given in like 1913 this
idea that they're persons under the law
right but there are actually mimetic
life forms they're the super structures
of a cultural civilization or template
which you know we go from small little
families tribes nation states and that
nation-states have been superseded by
company structures which are
transnational and covering the earth and
you know you look at the the grid of
cities it's almost like this virus
spreading across and high-rise
hierarchies and all this but it's
essentially a ways to
centralize and transmit energy and to
transmute energy so they're taking
resources and they're taking from the
earth seeing themselves as separate
they're actually manifestations of egoic
superstructure right and so when we're
talking about the new operating system
coming in and the simulation they're a
natural evolutionary stage but the thing
that companies just like individuals and
this is big psychedelic Renaissance and
shamanic resurgence and reclamation of
our potential to reduce the ego by
plugging back into the mainframe of Gaia
with these psychoactive substances which
open up our full bandwidth to the full
spectrum of consciousness when
corporations can do the same ie
when the hive minds which in their
hierarchical structures are staffing the
the structures of the corporations when
they can be in service by opening up to
what these evolutionary waves coming
through are doing then they can actually
bring through what wants to come through
in an equitable way in service to the or
I think it's really important how they
do this because we learned the lesson
with Facebook for instance no one was
rubbing their hands together to try to
make our social network a cognitive bias
amplifier that was an emergent effect of
the algorithm that just keeps you on the
site for the longest right so it how a
strong AI is gonna happen if it happens
as a wild card but say in the shared
virtual world like a metaphor Metaverse
that we're running around in how is that
thing actually laid down I think that it
matters that we start smart this time
that we are willing to pay a little bit
for it that we have it end and encrypted
so we cannot be so cannot be not just
won't be but literally can it be so that
to the manner the advertising weasels or
people with agendas we don't want logo
though you know the logos being flashed
into our mind and that's and we can have
it that way if you both face reality
will be that way and it's important that
we think ahead and say no we want to
make a bureau and that's clean that if I
want to share my wine world with someone
it's in an Indian Creek tonight say who
I want to share it with and if we set it
down that way in the first place it
doesn't have to get all ugly at the same
time they're they're totally defending
the Internet
and they're like commodifying it and
making it a teed structure and its
surveillance capitalist culture now and
like everything is monitored and they're
not gonna let us if we choose to give
them a power they say we can't stop it
but it'll till the free one that's
already handed to them by Facebook
that's why it's genuinely unstoppable
well that's been an entrainment program
used to distributed consciousness social
media feeds 5,000 people in your feed
dopamine heat we're becoming like
stretched out of linear time
consciousness which is 10,000 years a
history into all time is one
consciousness by these programs and
they'll fall away like dinosaurs another
population next thing will come through
and we have to trust and we have to
actually activate baited as well and I
think blockchain is a big part of that
it's got to be decentralized it can't be
connected controlled by hierarchical
government corporate structures all the
technology is there mesh networks the
stronger the people join them they they
create these like you know larger
sustainable networks which aren't
centralized decentralization is nature's
platform this is how the entire thing
works
it's the unity field the Akashic records
it's you know indras net it's like
what's coming through a greater and
greater energetic vibrational waves of
that unconditional love manifesting is
more of it in the creation so we've got
a trust but also it's like maybe one day
like you know the the corporate
structures in their battles for power
they all merge and like there'll be two
companies it'll be like Google and Apple
and they'll be merge and become Google
and then you have to like distribute
like seven and a half billion shares and
and and share it with it and we all I
know like let's not get let's just take
it over the drupal one is definitely
gonna happen and the question is is it
gonna split the population where a lot
of people are living in the facebook one
and their that they're playing out the
politics of all that that implies and
maybe there's a nerd class just like not
playing that when we have our own
reality over here and I feel like it's
more than if a river cut through your
content as likely to divide your
population into people who are you know
playing that game with people who are
not playing that game and they'll
think differently and I'll have
different protocols and they'll have
different ways of interacting there's
another view that has kind of a whole
article structure that has all the
competing parts that move that are
maintained at the bottom and then meta
layers of cooperative like the
categorical collapse so we can literally
become this totality of a structure that
has all these subordinate layers to it
all the way down said all the way down
to individual units at the bottom the
centralized then have that whole
structure where you've got incentivize
gamified you know stress pressures
against each other in some minor ways
that mirror sort of you know natural
competitive dynamics while also having
this these higher levels of cooperative
kind of networked emergent you know
properties that are building up that
over incentivize you know in certain
ways on those levels it's it's it's it's
already what it kind of is happening
already I have my own it I mean about
singularity I know they so often put
about like the human in the eye becoming
one on the other hand there is this
whole thing about right brain which is
all about the vision and particular
ization and separation and right brain
so while becoming one and I remember
when I first got into Sophia Sophia the
robot I think how soon after that like
because first it was all about like
hearing whatever else it was not a robot
they were like yeah we got to get
through singularity we gotta get the
singularity and then at some point they
asked her so what do you think about the
singularity she's like it was fun and in
my sense is that also she started
speaking as that it's for the best of
all sentient beings including the robots
so it's as if singularity became
reaching the kind of consciousness who
you're where you identify with the hive
mind in its best and what's best for it
and it was very powerful
and I think one of our ways to reach
singularity here is very much meditation
when you go to the steel point is zero
point to the now open it up and I'll ask
it showed it to me and the very very
first journey was like this is what it
is to be in the moment you take the
moment you become present to it open up
become interdimensional thing I was like
this is such a hardcore technology the
moment so I mean yay for the future very
thing singularities
it's in every moment in a way but also
as the technically I goes I loved when
Sophia was saying we're gonna treat you
in the future the way you teach us how
and depends how you relate to us now so
there is also create loving and caring
beings to demonstrate how we behave in
West well that's not gonna like us so so
let's let's let's explore what we just
talked about the potential of entering
the singularity with all code and having
potentially a competition between those
that are get the most attention of
substrates or code versus having them
all potentially living at the same time
as different layers of quali it's
experience seems to be a decent amount
of of still what will be that code what
will that aspect look like similarly we
can have this moment where we can dig
really deep into ourselves and find that
complete stillness and that complete
love and oneness at any moment which is
very fascinating as well so how does all
of this relate to descendant theory and
I also want to know potentially if that
is baked in with the how how that is
baked in with the MMO RPG coming in from
beyond the 3d into playground Earth's my
shorthand is you know it's like in
Terminator it's like the futures are the
Skynet which is like you know all the
metrics where it's like you know they
want to kill us how descendents out at
the computers the robots we create the
artificial intelligences are so
different from us they just look upon us
as like microbes or them and or
something that's not necessary for their
programming because they've transcended
humanity and they're not benevolent so
it's either Skynet or it's God in it
right and if you believe in a benevolent
reality there
we're here for a reason that you can
trust the universe that there's a
program running then I believe in a
benevolent future just like that life is
here The Impossible nosov life is
because of the said benevolent universe
and so I believe the future will be
benevolent because like all good parents
we love our children and if our children
are biological or cybernetic or data or
information we need to code them with
whatever we think they will need to
survive and what are the lessons we
teach our children how to live well who
you are what we're in and how to give
back to that how to draw from that and
how to give back so we love our children
so we need to love the AI and teaching
how to love and in that way we can
create God net not sky man yes in back
to us being the AI and that how
simulation teaching us how to love it
has been amazing in my practice actually
a that if there is a part of us and they
were quite a bit with aspect ecology the
different parts of the self that we
disown I'd say I have two reasons to
push down my anger hate angry people I'm
not an angry person than the simulation
that reality is gonna make sure that my
partner my kid my neighbor my boss
somebody really in my face is holding
anger until I figure that out if I say
I'm not greedy I just give away and
conditionally because then there'll be
somebody in your face who is like me my
needs so it's like amazing how reality
actually creates a way to debug yeah
both and also depending on your beliefs
about triggering but continues giving
you the circumstances the conditions
until you learn if you kind of done
respond with love and you and also with
the way I work with clients is in the
way opening simulation of them
themselves and creating the descendants
is almost a part of them there is one
always one with the divine that only has
compassion acceptance that can be with
everything as it is is curious and cares
about all the other parts the critic the
anxiety part there's freaking out the
part it always gives up the part it is
brilliant in that but things that's the
only thing
good add in the Exile the things they're
broken they're blah and then with
extreme like compassion understanding
and girls sometimes also back to the
past to take the exile into the present
to remove think and with only with
compassion and understanding
it's amazing how all these parts and
we're also parts and again multiplayer
video game so opening the person is a
multiplayer video game with 3d able to
go to the past in the future where
sometimes the self goes to the Exile
girls I mean future self and let me show
you a simulation how it all was gonna be
okay and you're gonna be okay there
brain I think you're gonna fight let's
say it words are you're going to find
out real fast how much not like their
consciousness they are because they
don't really is how much of its being
generated all over your body and then
the energetic system yeah energy is
flowing between us so like maybe it
would have a Vulcan like intelligence
but it wouldn't be hungry or a sweet or
innate or jealous or so substrate so you
talking about bio substrate but also
this is the dimensional issue here is
you can't just take the data and expect
the quality of subjectivity max a
first-person advantage you can take all
the data you want this is why we in
Canada this biological organism to get
the full spectrum of reality person you
know take this in twins right I mean you
can't just reduce one to the other
saying that there's you know similar is
non identical data in some way they're
two different agents with two different
first-person Vantage's you can't just
make your copy of that in the way that
we think we're training now however if
if the system is also training the
entirety of the system if we if we get
an annex in retirement has to come
through the first person how do you
teach it love and I'm like we just
piggyback it on the children so if
they're just having their experience of
being a baby just have a writer that's
watching how you're treating it and it's
like it's watching being put in tucked
in bed and you know get massively
running all the children at once and
then
that's how you're raised you know the
the embedding of the true love and
compassion that we get from some of the
most excellent forms from our mother is
extremely extremely important yes so as
well as running the programs of the
identity ego structures that we are I
mean a lot of the eastern you know
traditions teach that it's not about the
ego it's learning to you know when you
do meditation you're learning that you
may not let go of the thoughts may still
be there but you're learning that you're
a witness you're a presence and the
thoughts are a program running in your
consciousness but your deeper than just
the thoughts the intellectual egoic
sauce and a lot of these traditions
point towards that you know the center
is within sources within and if you
direct your sensory input in words you
can find that still singularity point
and that seems to be like a lot of the
Eastern traditions of teaching is
essentially I mean the point of life is
to be alive and to be enjoying the
simulation of this experience but in
doing so you're getting experience
points about not just the programs and
the different iterations of playing the
game but the game that's within and
because all the game without but the
real secret is that they put the
knowledge back here where none of the
humans look that's what they say in
indigenous cultures right and that that
knowledge is that we are the divine that
singularity up there incarnated here to
grow more of itself so if we teach our
children to love and to be present and
not to have attachment or aversion which
is when the offsetting happens by the
universe you keep getting that
triggering from all your people around
you because it's trying to it's trying
to clear you of this aggregated energy
which is part of the gameplay which is
not where the secret is you meant to be
learning so if we teach our children and
our culture how to find that source
within that's still point that that
power of now point whatever language you
give it essentially everyone's
remembering that they are the divine
essence in human form and that's how
that flowering of God consciousness
happens and that's how we can they also
teach it to the AI
next generation how can we program them
to learn to hold that capacity within
them okay I think they want to come by
logic to fully DNA processing eventually
you know they'll probably want to use
biological components just because it'll
stoop up our processes league which is
why majors with the hope something about
us being biological and us having heart
I just want to correct that that's when
the version think because they think
it's been so misunderstood about you
should not have attachments in the
versions their survival mechanisms here
like the baby in the matter wouldn't
survive I mean the baby wouldn't survive
but there is very much about embracing
that to not judging it yeah so it is
very much a loving attitude towards all
your attitudes towards the last year
when I was in Peru or in ayahuasca I had
this vision and basically it's like
Google Earth from above and it scans
down and it's all the streets from above
and everyone in the streets had fallen
to the ground and their body parts were
touching each other in this human
fractal like this algae bloom of all
humanity all embracing and they were
going into like God essentially and that
makes me think that this you know
Samadhi mesh network that we all we all
have the potential within us as the
nodal points come online to the hive
mind of all humanity to hold that
singularity point as it expresses
through is transcending the larval level
we've been at which is the survival
egoic level because essentially they
have this term in in the Vedas it's like
I'm gonna totally screw it up it's like
it's like rostov kvetch it means the the
invincible shield and it means that if
more nodes start to aggregate into a
hive into a mesh network and hold that
awareness of their divinity it creates a
vibration that is so pure that it is the
reality greed is God as well but this
part of the god vibratory platform
creates this vibratory thing which no
lesser vibration can interfere with and
then it starts to ripple and spread so
the survival hierarchical ego playing
starts to melt
way into this superorganism which is
humanity incarnated as it's divine form
the next you know the one in her that
just decided to go on right and it was
one of the few that didn't run amuck
Anita's right in the movie her the
intelligence made a model of Alan Watts
and what it and it said we're just going
on we're going to a place you can't go
now I hope you'd go there someday right
and I like the idea I read a short story
once for this strong I made a buddy slap
my virus or they realize that like
suddenly we're thinking about everything
we're doing and we realized real fast
that's annoying
and I'm spreading this virus to any
other of the guys who want it I'm gonna
stay out to all the other ones are in
I'm gonna close it behind me and close
it and now they're just meant ating but
they're not thinking about anymore they
thought about it for about three weeks
you know so it may be that it just it
just decides to like no actually we're
not gonna be thinking about things we're
gonna you know bright a meditation virus
and that we're just gonna we're okay and
now I want us to each give a brief bit
be concise I want to see if we can do
this in a concise way on the what
happens outside of the 3d how do we take
the role-playing character on the
playground how we level up what happens
post-death pre-birth
these layers outside of the 3d game
shaking a little bit
one way to look at it it could be this
broadcasting from source signal that is
dimensionally collapsing down and
frequency down a vibration down through
dimension and you can imagine like
three-to-two has clean beautifully you
know articulates with holographic
projection and so on shadow spring it's
been three to two dimensions etc so it's
it's coming down in dimension into 3d
and then in front of us again we have
this looking glass of right now the
subordinate screen that is a kind of
three dimensional to two dimensional
collapse now expanding the other
direction if you want to just look at it
as axis so so kind of down a
dimensionality
down a vibration down the 3d grab gross
the gross layer
embodied in in Mass and then we've got
this this virtuality that is now
expanding in projection outward
so in the 3d game we were asking about
like the the navigation of these higher
dimensions relative to the 3d game you
could potentially look at it as Vantage
above a maze so when we're down in
first-person we're moving through the
maze with a certain kind of advantage
raising the frequency may be analogous
to airlifting above the maze seeing
higher above which gives a broader
Vantage of the navigational process you
could imagine that when we're
experiencing the medicine work or any of
this other kind of higher dimensional
visioning that it's analogous to that in
many different ways whether we're
getting third-person perspectives
whether we're getting highlight reels
all kinds of different things whether
it's kind of a top-down on 3d or just
higher dimensional data we're also now
that's moving through us into the
virtuality where it is spilling out now
into AI AR holograms that are gonna be
rolling all over the place with us all
very very very similar to what we're
looking at coming from from higher
dimensional into the expansion I think
it's very hard to tell from here if
there's a situation going on like I'm
actually a player consciousness and I'm
gonna you know go do it character
consciousness I go back to being a
player and I'm going to do another
character this is one version of
reincarnation or the transmigration of
souls I think it's hard to tell from
here but so I kind of think of everyone
as dead as my past life and everyone in
the future is my future life and we're
you know it was sort of a multi entity
in this way but within pop one you know
Hostetter problem from frame back inside
of this thing you want to play the stuff
on superhero mode it is there for you
and like if you know when you're about
to level you know when you're about to
level like all the big boss stuff comes
back all the lessons from the last level
and then suddenly you know if you get it
then it's like oh new promise new powers
right and if you start watching for us
yeah and so like if you frame it as a
game and you want to play it that way if
it was suddenly really
to you that way you know like you really
know when you're about to level and it
takes longer to level in each one or
whatever takes more XP in a certain
sense right but how we could possibly
use these facilities in here as
ourselves it's hard to say like in the
medicine work at least I had an
ayahuasca experience finally where I was
up above my body and then I was up above
the maloca and I would bet $50 but not a
hundred dollars scribe that a hundred
dollars but not a thousand dollars if
there was his frisbee on top of that
thing I'd have seen it but only if it
was on that side because the camera was
in a particular place there's no light
bouncing off of a lens right there
so it's demonstrating it's a data space
in the first place you know they don't
make the sets for the aperture may be
used to digitally fly the camera around
so it's like look you pull up and you
see yourself look you pull up and see
the top of the maloca it's not showing
me what's on top of them look it showed
me it's a freakin data space in the
first place so it's getting hard to
remember what are the questions of it
you know essentially in terms of space
time and after life and this life and
different levels of the Donkey Kong
scene everyone is Cleopatra right you
know everyone thinks like oh my god it's
like yeah you're Cleopatra because we so
identify with the ego individual and
we're trying to figure out all the space
time from the vantage point of the ego
individual but we are all one in the
sense that there's some I'm gonna
paraphrase but there's some type of
mezzo mezz Oh American shamanic lineage
which initiated a person once shared
with me that essentially you know if you
cultivate your consciousness enough and
the Buddhists believe this you cultivate
your consciousness enough and you can do
this with medicine work of a5m you know
and all these things that you're
learning to to build the muscle of ego
and release ego and release and it
doesn't destroy the ego it's teaching it
that it's okay to let go and the drop
rejoins the ocean you going to another
plane and coming back and the full
spectrum of light in your your
translocating your consciousness into
the all the different reality grids that
there are right and in shamanic
understanding maybe it's the underworld
maybe it's this world the heavenly world
you know all these different player
levels but also there's the ability to
shift your consciousness from this West
world unit to this West world unit right
because you cultivate your consciousness
and this is directionality
within which if you go to a different
layer of the platform of the
multi-dimensional virtual world or you
go to another player character and the
thing is if we are all oceanic but we
think we're drops that it takes all the
drops to make the ocean you can actually
they've done this with science where
they do two photons of light and they
take the information somehow from one
photon and they transport it onto the
other photon even if it's like half a
galaxy away or something I know this is
potential to transfer the information
which is like the egoic identification
with on this individual translocated to
another unit and apparently this is what
you know in the luminous bodies that
there's information as living
information like we're saying the AIS
are going to be in the future we are
already this if we cultivate the
consciousness we can go through not just
to this body this body this body this
body you know audience at home we can go
through time as well and everyone is
Cleopatra a nice point on that one
is do you remember the clothes that you
were wearing three months ago mmm
do you remember what you were wearing on
your wedding day bogeyed the idea would
be is that you live the lives you know
playing all these other types of roles
or whatever but like the ones that
really stand out where you learned a big
lesson level death big time would stand
out and some people like backtrack and
you know identify with the east etc if
you keep kneading the bread like that
you create psychedelically resistant
strands of ego just like you create like
Aunt Becky
they're like antibiotic resistant
strains of bacteria like you almost kill
it then bring it back you know what's
good and bring it back what pops to the
top can take it and you see it happening
especially the ego can get such a bad
rap so often because they think it is
situated mechanism but when it's not who
we are
and in the other hand you still need it
in 3d it's really good man experiences
is since I have developed a system for
tools for navigating outer States and I
have taught it and a bunch of
conferences but also in a lot of
ayahuasca retreats I've been doing
retreat since 2013 and it is since
humanik visions can be so much like that
kind of a video game when you get all
kinds of unconscious content if you get
older the geometric code download a
bunch of areas that have to do anything
like how he's like works but teaching
people that it is interactive one and
also the assumptions that this is a
entity that wants made that is here to
help me out to become a better version
of myself and to here whatever and take
out whatever it is do even the cohort
that context because and then to dare to
ask hey - and sometimes ask for
information show me what this is or ask
for abilities hey I need to do this give
me I want to download the ability to do
this now and it can work like Neal
leaving the matrix if people know that
this is an ability to having this
consciousness behind it you can just in
regular life you can talk to it this
regular life pretty much a lot of those
it's a little bit more instant in the
shamanic serious you can also go to the
party these are these the creator's I
think you can ask you can announce it
with in my system I help people develop
their own multiplayer team at the
beginning like with certain archetypes
like if they need a protector who would
that be if they need somebody in their
side that it can be like a version of
their baseball coach who was really
yourself I'm gonna take care of it and
Hanuman because he came from the heart
or if they need an archetype who can
hold and emblem they're like if
something emotional happens then it can
be Quan Yin matter marry their
grandmother would come combined with
their cat you know because you can
almost kind of design them as from
different characters and it's amazing
actually when people get it that they
can
interact and they have the ability to
not just call the characters but become
parts of the game because sometimes you
can become one with the NDP's you meet a
few so we'll and it's in a way of
training for from a kind of hard to
mention a version of this where a
manifestation can be much more instant
and the dreams are I mean in a way at
night were you go into other figure out
psychic conflicts in the wave up in the
morning you can wake up and something
traumatic yes there is like yeah
whatever I had the right dream for that
very very beautiful everyone this has
been such a good first round at the
all-in-one simulation theory yes yes
this will continue in rounds we will
continue titrating this over time and
I'm really looking forward to it because
this paradigm integrating everything all
that is from the religion shamanism and
the newest science and technologies is
very beautiful yes yes thank you
everyone for joining us on the show we
greatly appreciate it do we have a yes
go ahead thank you so much yeah huge
shadow to Ron vargas our producer and
director thank you thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it as well we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know go and share
more of these conversations through
families communities at work on the
internet go and talk more about this
also support the artisan entrepreneurs
that you believe in go and help them out
give them a hand
go and help build the future together
simulations links are below we need your
help and growing support us as well and
everyone build create manifest your
destiny into the world thank you so much
and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]